we've already spent a lot of time
talking about how neat carbon is for
life and for biology and for chemical
reactions so much so that there's a
whole field of organic chemistry devoted
to studying the chemistry of molecules
that involve carbon and one of the
things that carbon or two of the things
that carbon will often bond with are
itself and with hydrogens so much so
that there's an entire class of of
molecules that are only made up of
carbons and hydrogens and we call these
it's a very creative name we call them
hydrocarbons
and you will see many many types of pure
hydrocarbons and you'll see many other
types of molecules that at least are
partially hydrocarbons or are based on
hydrocarbons so it's a really
interesting thing to study here's three
examples of hydrocarbons these all have
the prefix f in the beginning of them
because they have a chain their longest
chain has two carbons and if you want to
study how to name hydrocarbons or
actually organic compounds in general i
encourage you to look at the organic
chemistry section of khan academy where
we go into depth on it but this is just
going to get you just kind of dip our
toe in the water just so we get a little
bit familiar so these all have the
prefix f which says our longest chain of
carbon we're gonna have two carbons over
here but then we see that the ending is
different over here we have ethane and
it's it's an ain because we have a
single bond over here
this over here we have an en and that's
because we have a double bond we have at
least one double bond in that chain that
and the carbon chain is only two carbons
over here and it's ethyne here because
we have a triple bond the general term
for a carbon chain that has no double or
triple bonds is an alkane this is a
specific form of an alkane ethane that
has two carbons if the general form for
carbons that have a double bond that's
an alkene actually let me write these
general terms down so i could write al
alkane
alkane is the general term for a chain
of carbons that has no double or triple
bonds and specifically this is ethane if
i were to speak generally here i'd say
alkene i would say alkyne right over
here let's think a little bit about how
this bond affects affects its shape
well here i have a single bond so it
essentially forms two tetrahedrons with
one of the carbons at each of the
centers of those tetrahedrons for
example on the left hand side here when
i when i draw this bond popping when i
draw it like this it means that it's
popping out and when i draw it like this
with these lines that means it's going
into into the screen so i could draw a
tetrahedron that looks that looks like
this that's the base of it and then the
top of it is at this other carbon and it
has it has this carbon at the center and
i could also draw another tetrahedron
that has this carbon at the center this
carbon is top
and it would look it would look
something
it would look something
like
it would look something like this so for
at least for this molecule you have
these the the shape is kind of it looks
like these two tetrahedrons that are
kind of overlapping with each other and
because these carbons are are they have
a single bond in between them
these two tetrahedrons can rotate so
they could rotate
they could rotate around they could
rotate around that single bond
now things are a little bit different
when you have a double bond when you
have a double bond like this it actually
forces all of these all of these atoms
in this molecule to be in the same plane
so this right over here this ethene this
is planar this is planar right over here
and this double bond locks it into place
there's not going to be any rotation
when you have a triple bond not only are
you not going to have any rotation but
it's going to make the whole thing it's
going to make the whole thing a linear
molecule so when we're talking about a
shape we're talking about these
molecules their conformation how do they
arrange themselves in three dimensions
and if you're curious what these are
ethane is a component of natural gas
most of natural gas is methane methane
is just
so if i were to write methane
most of natural gas is methane which is
just one
which is just one carbon bonded to
four hydrogens that's methane right over
here this is
most of
this is the biggest constituent of
natural gas but you're going to find a
little bit of ethane in there
ethene which is often known as ethylene
this has many industrial uses but maybe
most interestingly it can be used as a
it's a plant hormone that can be used to
ripen fruit
ethyne or
most commonly known as a acetylene this
can be used because it burns very very
hot it can be used to fuel blow torches
so once again you know these are they
seem similar but they can be used for
very very different things and i could
go all day showing more and more
different types of hydrocarbons but
here's just a little bit more variety
just so we can think about how they're
named and the different forms they take
and these are just three of the
different types of molecules you might
find in the gasoline that you have in
your car and there's many many more than
than just these and that's because you
mix them with oxygen put them in an
engine and and spike and spark them
right they burn well they're they're
good fuels to to power cars but just so
get familiar with the naming mechanism a
little bit more this is pentane it's an
alkane with five carbons one two three
four five carbons in its longer longest
chain that's what's called pentane
because hydrogens are all of the other
bonds that carbons are forming sometimes
you'll see a shorthand where something
like a pentane instead of drawing all
the c's and h's it would be drawn like
this
it could be drawn like this where you
assume that there's just a carbon at
each of these points over there so you
actually don't have to draw the carbon
and then if you don't see if you don't
if something's not bonded to a carbon
and there's no other
atom that is drawn in that a carbon is
bonded to you assume it's just a bunch
of hydrogen so this is a shorthand for
pentane which is exactly this molecule
here and you see it has this kind of it
has this bent shape because carbon is
each of the carbons are trying to get to
that tetrahedral type of shape
now this this is cyclohexane
once again it's an alkane we have no
double bonds here hex is the prefix
because you have six carbons in your
longest chain one two three or you could
say your cycle in this case five
six and the cyclo is because instead of
it just being a instead of it being an
open instead of it just being an open
chain it's connected at the end and it
forms it forms an actual cycle
this over here looks a little bit more
complex you see the ene at the end and
that's because the longest chain has a
double bond right over here and the
butte this is the prefix for four this
means that our longest chain has four
carbons and you see that one two three
four carbons but then on this number two
carbon not only do you have your double
bond there but you also have a methyl
group a methyl group one carbon meth is
the meth is the prefix meth is the
prefix for one
so anyway the goal of this video is
really just to get you a little bit
familiar with with hydrocarbons and and
to think about how they'll be useful in
chemistry and parts of and and and
you'll see many molecules in biology
that have hydrocarbon parts that have
chains of hydrocarbons attached to them
so we can think about the properties
associated with them